ils se sont approchés aussi près qu'il
le pouvait du kremlin drapeaux au vent
téléphone allumé un geste de résistance
et surtout de solidarité d'autres sinon
boni c'est pour que navale nez et
puissent être soignés pour qu'ils soient
libres de cette jeune femme
oui f2 et c'est notre devoir de tout
risque et même d'être arrêté des
centaines l'entêté dans plusieurs villes
de russie à moscou la police était aux
aguets partout mais a fait preuve de
retenue cette fois ci ça ne nous posons
connu ça ne pouvait arrêter à tout
moment pour sauver mon cher 2 ils ont
essayé de me tuer des forges été
emprisonnés dont on connaît les risques
mais l'opposant vladimir car amoureuse a
connu des plus hautes instances du
pouvoir
tenez quand même à se joindre à la foule
est-ce que je dois être ici parce que le
kremlin essaie de tuer
alexeï navalni lentement douloureusement
est donc une façon dont le monde entier
tôt le voir et ce n'est pas normal
la femme d'alex et navale n'est ioulia
était là aussi une des rares de
l'organisation qui est encore libre de
circuit ces autres associés ont presque
tous été arrêtés avant la manifestation
un avant goût de ce qui les attend lundi
quand toute la machine kalex et navale
n'est a mis sur pied au fil des ans y
compris sa fondation sera désigné groupe
extrémiste par la russie donc banni dans
tout le pays mais on reviendra encore et
encore même s'il déclare illégaux
illégales les organisations les
fondations les structures n'importe quoi
et qui pour orion faire avec le fait
qu'il ya des millions déjà en russie qui
voit on à venir très différent différent
de celui qui se destine avec vladimir
poutine qui plus tôt dans la journée
s'adresser à la nation comme il le fait
chaque année mais cette fois sur fond
tensions presque inédite avec l'europe
et les états unis pour qu'ils avaient un
message
quiconque osera franchir la ligne rouge
avec la russie va le regretter comme
jamais rien auparavant a dit président
samy alors qu'il subit les foudres de
l'ouest pour son déploiement de troupes
à la frontière de l'ukraine ou encore
pour le sort de la vanille
il prévient qu'en cas de provocation la
riposte de l'ue sera dure et rapide
bristol jaune
le message que vladimir poutine en voit
aujourd'hui à l'occident s'applique tout
autant à ceux ici qui lui tiennent tête
il va en finir une fois pour toutes avec
la fondation d'alexis navale n'est toute
la dissidence qu'il a semé le message
est clair personne ne lui dictera la loi
en russie
et si thammarat altérait secoue
radio-canada moscou